conversation it was a very important
moment fresh air to be here and I'm
talking to you today about the research
sighs in could I did my dissertation
research while I was getting my PhD and
so the University of Washington first
question everyone asks me is if you're
going to the University of Washington
why did you end up in New York your
dissertation research and the answer is
because i wanted to do research with a
community that I did work with as a
social work practitioners as activists
and it was still very much in New York
City I also wanted to do community-based
participatory research and most of my
relationships were still in New York
City go to assemble a few the advisory
board and do all the things that I
wanted to do my dissertation research
analyst
so the name of my talk is both our
voices relational approach to my history
improves would you have justice involves
LGBTQ adults both our voices is because
I think that your own story of moving
through a doctoral program and taking on
a research padded active appreciating
IRB and negotiating the quality of
different and all those things your own
story very much she comes apart women
into the stories the participants who
you're interviewing I also really wanted
to have to say that free a positive
assertion oral history I'm good it's a
very relational dialogical reciprocal
process that is very much shaped by who
you are in relation to peers talking to
and I think that I come from social work
which is still very kind of scientific
method there are many of us who are
making stuff and within that sort of
Western scientific or on TV show
yourself in the research you know your
social i understand you're an objective
observer of population and i feel like
this dehumanizing way of thinking about
both the people that were doing research
with but also by stroking and so i
commented eposide that you know I was
great as well from side to this
encounter and the research was really
relationally based in terms of any
reason cells but a whole in terms of us
having a comedian Missouri board which i
did with initially with people fighting
for my work before activism or from
other kinds of friendships
research in social services and yet
social work per kilo still a lot of ways
invince Eliza's young where trans
people's experiences so people are
starting to look at this
disproportionate representation and why
are
how are they what's the relationship
between these systems how are they what
we're learning that the pathways it to
the jj's it's emanating out of the child
welfare system are we needed by a lot of
different factors including a history of
child welfare involvement family
acceptance is a really big one has there
been a family crap she related to use
sexual orientation or gender identity
have been able to reconcile with their
family experiences within school there's
been a lot of attention and possibly
years to the role of school bully algae
bt q young people experiences in
juvenile justice system and experiences
within the community where we're
learning that particularly for being
queer trans youth of color others
actually a lot of profiling have any bad
off for Smith and so that's also
contributing to the really high rates of
Jersey
or experienced for 65 million
between involved in another study
approximately twenty percent of average
Herman Eric Brewer lower representation
in non-urban areas we know that LGBTQ
youth experience a lot of harassment
we'll listen the gay lesbian straight
education network does a school clients
are getting animal or biannual basis but
in a recent survey of LGBTQ identified
students between the ages of 13 and 21
without that eighty-four percent the big
and gender students report being
verbally harassed forty percent report
being harassed
we assaulted one third of bullying
students who reported bling to school
officials said that administrators did
nothing to address the issue now this
last statistic we're going to talk a
little bit later in the presentation
about something that's finally getting
some national recognition which is this
little boozy pipeline I think this
highlights the ways in which that is
using the experience my LGBTQ young
people so a typical scenario might be
that person is haunted and taunted and
haunted and taunted insulted and they
report this to their school
administrator on his dog or they
reported to us a teacher and the teacher
trans reported nursing television and
then pop in one day is when you keep
being taunted you might finally fight
back and thus when unfortunately a lot
of pieces law enforcement steps in
you know the secondary data analysis
based on a population-based sample they
found that non-heterosexual adolescents
suspicion girls are disproportionately
sanctioned by schools and creole justice
authorities despite the fact that
they're not muted or elaborating
behavior and that this may be
contributing to their own presentation
and the research you'll hear stories
that kind of endorse this assertion my
own are LGBT pathways in two ways in
which headlines or citizens of my own
all doors are created at the
intersection systems the research
questions I was asking for this
particular study were how LGBT key to
happiness experience growth detention
facilities in the juvenile justice
system understand negotiate the Congress
of their sexual orientation gender and
gender identity in relation to age race
ethnicity and other aspects of identity
so I really wanted to look at the
intersections of different aspects of
people's identity I've got just a you're
a dead woman but
because of the facilities
so just an overview my research design
each of these things india was using
it was participatory research
orientation so that
scholars who previously in Madison
begins with an ethical responsibility to
address processes of injustice by
bringing to light underlying obscure
operations power the explicitly
political aims of the researcher
reflexivity so that researches
reflections of is Natalie a single work
accessible to critique an evaluation and
so we talked a lot about that you all
were asking me questions how how do you
talk about the context in oral history
interview and I was just into the search
every person is going to elicit a
different kind of story from people
before you know we're each bringing all
we are intimate encounter
nature for me I also it's probably was a
social work practice your roots was
really concerned with example feelings
emotional impact that research have sort
of a form of data in another today no
computation to this
in other words in our society I was for
the aquarium curse myself and so I think
that was something that I needed to
watch out for in terms of my own
experiences of knock people's narratives
my professional identities as a senior
researcher academic
I wanted to be my full of institutional
into the interview however I felt about
that institutional presence it was there
and then I was raised by my family of
origin I was not raised in the foster
care system I don't know that
experiences like I was not my family so
there are community-based participatory
research it is mental stress that I
think it seeks to involve community
doors organizational representatives and
academic researchers as partners
collaborative form of research that
enables knowledge
particular
activism anniversary weird activist
responds to the HW so was first emerging
and it was present mostly in game grid
the government and medical community was
currently neglectful towards this you
know buyers that was stated to so many
people some groups that have to really
organized around dematha that research
these different categories are not
mutually exclusive five members were
initially created through the existing
relationships I had from either work or
and then based on those five hours two
additional numbers were recruited
because the hours were like this person
really needs to table or
I rely on people's generosity and doing
this research and there's not there are
genetic resources for working in this
way as these were people who just were
really really good work really love
these questions asked and answered and
we were incredibly generous with their
in terms of hydration numbers
represented arranged sexual orientation
the research
organizations anymore activist groups
organized by it for young queer and
transgender that was something that was
really inspiring once the call was
circulated it was kind of and went
around between different networks of
organized we're in catskill which to me
was so beautiful and just people to
their community to LGBTQ campus centers
in New York city-based colleges and
universities and other community-based
research and our history products
internet-based list of your people that
I care if you'd actually refer them
participants to study which player
generations before
for more time and sometimes that to do
with the fact that we actually covered
material relatively quickly other times
do the fact up this is people in other
situations are always changing so we may
have intended to do a second interview
but something had changed contact or in
terms of orientation and I think one of
the largest a novel is just absolutely
fluidity of identities a sexual
orientation and gender identity
so the self terms at pulled loose
identify themselves were AG stud bull
and Athena pfm aggressive aggressive
bisexual woman math teacher and female a
lot of these are really geographically
specific identities so if I were to be
doing this research in Seattle probably
got a very different this is manganese
in terms of race for the black or latina
from the dr credibly over bull three
identified as mulberry chiller mixed
race irish german African American West
participants have actually been a witch
shelters and other
actually
I was first exposed to
it's been very active so teenagers and
coherent narrative any places can be
really really hard and so sitting and
doing this really really frustrated or
sad or you know make us laugh questions
and so they were a couple young people
really this was a moment where they
actually wanted to like get that
information
in relation to the research
and this work has stories as memory a
former resist resistance against
forgetting and institutionally Richard
communities experienced during a
particular moment so the political
external moment which this was happening
was one when the juvenile justice system
was in the midst of really big changed
in New York State so just within the
last year through an initiative called
posta home youth from york city
facilities if there were juvenile
justice involved in its term that they
we're going to be placed in detention
are now actually either being raised in
facilities in new york city or being
awkward community-based alternatives and
so this representative really been
changed by the way JJ systems operated
for you
earlier facilities and history which is
compensated forty dollars each using a
structured interview Valley News probes
were modified new teams and merged in
that arias was diving operation the
community advisory board who helped
develop questions and it could help
excavated to family school interactions
with law enforcement
spirituality experiences
we are the experiences that we have
because they printed out our voice
becomes a part of our voice and so
trying to identify what that works are
those voices are
so
voice of the in the narration
just one story right it's never just you
know there's a lot of things happening
when someone shares their story with you
and there was sort of building for that
contradictory to the dominant voice in
relation to the research questions I
have no idea i started doing this how
labor-intensive it would be i'm so glad
that i used it i think it's a really
rich and powerful with analyzing data
but dunno issues Jason it's very very
soon so basically you're taking all the
notes and your hope you're actually
coding on the interview itself using
different colors as combined
and writing up sort of sour interview
basically so it's the final stage where
you're kind of pulling it all together
and looking at how it speaks to the
specific research questions that a boss
nope
experiences to the story
in some cases pathway to child welfare
juvenile justice involvement had to do
with interest between family fracture
related to sexual orientation gender
identity and child welfare and you have
justice involvement so for a lot of the
young people of smoking to their have an
experience a family fracture that
resulted in there being other place in
the foster care system or removed from
ultra family and that often made for
fortunately we don't have therapeutic
methods that people
to prevent an orbital fracture a lot of
participants described schools as places
and sometimes characterized by hostile
environments but another thing that was
happening was interruption related to
multiple moves within within the system
so every time you move home you very
often change schools and that made it
really hard for people to finish school
so if you're being sent to a juvenile
detention facility that's in Syracuse
and your phone bedside you know you're
not going to have a certain medication
so I wanted to dialogue that revealed
one person spends sort of understanding
and construction of their own
so based on our statements believe I'm
in that particular situation i'm in a
particular area i know i feel energy or
something that seems like it's
homophobic well pronounced ever even say
I'm open she were they I'll come out
represent myself they tend to be open
that except for home cooking situation
I'm female wow I do useful of bathrooms
i am appealing today man today I'm using
the men soccer but cigarettes kill em
separate I've sit here and I don't put
pilot together it's for another person I
do
on the bus to use by fabolous we're
having frustrations or challenges or
emotions so good and it wasn't always
completely clear how much Anna due to
sexual orientation of generality and
what other stuff was going on the family
but very often it would get to a point
where American city made this out of
control and family court and file this
institution and that's what result in
that we've been said parallel stories of
parents who just didn't know how bad
it's going to get once they place their
child and the massiveness the system
your kid winner in there so I heard
stories of parents who wish to it will
wish certain services felt very
remorseful the day that she came from
the shower for a journey has only got 14
15 years old I was young fellow
kitchenette full lifetime story and
manages to hear from going to the group
home and then I'm almost crying because
she was just like I'm sorry I family
understood that I was transgender I mean
that I was transitioning maybe my heart
felt as if I was need to still thinking
you know she felt like I was going
against god it's her
a little boy the longest time you really
show me thank you I'm going to teach you
about you want to be important to show
you whatever you do he messed me up and
not only that even in elementary like
any school I went to my dental lab with
whether it be teachers or his expos
school was really fun justice also
talked about sanctions that robotics
from school that she felt like had to do
with her gender presentation I asked
actually if she was she felt like she'd
been punished for her to her
presentation all the times she would
always get phone calls
facilities in the community
it was bi masc Mary for your color that
you know when they were side by law
enforcement experiences based on the
reality that they were in fact something
else I was a profound lack of safety and
facilities histories of
a group of experience with I did not
search my pants is right here so its
pleated pants right here y'all crotch
area or Christopher Street popeyes
you're sitting there doing this for no
apparent Thursday night tee time for
last month is low so we just pull this
partner to get some I don't know twice
twice within three blocks difference 1s
papayas and then one x to the jewelry
store there are but a karaoke bar right
there what are you doing there why are
you stopping
which experienced community as their
earth is a huge clash of the new
backpack in there and so that has
resulted in a lot of the hardest to your
stories were actually experiences
violence in detention facilities and
certainly heard story violence between
more disturbing was what I heard about
a lot of people in detention facilities
are allowed restraining residents and it
was very clear based on these
testimonies that a lot of these cases
this was taking out a kind of sexualized
own sometimes a racist were transporting
tone that could be understood as
no acting out but instead of using force
why won't you let me talk to somebody
you know why are you giving up three
something's wrong you know I don't
really remember what I did but I just
remember being that selling you know you
all curvy this just makes me
stronger and I didn't like
into resilience
and I think that emerged was informal
kitchen network step to a place by the
ball team so the way the ball team works
is that there are community houses and
people engaged in different
my father was 13 when a mother's 22 my
method through wall I asked my mother my
father asked me and it was just like to
scoring the relationship in the ballroom
scene and they were just definitely all
routine and just figure out what I
wanted to do and people will talk to
talk to and you just form that bomb my
father's me and my mother and I are I
talked to my parents about a lot of the
same things that I
the organization of different people
it was huge
all right of the research for practice
policy community social worker if ulam
recommendations that I need
preservation hugely impactful
integrating self-identified strength
their application sexually-oriented apps
of excessive use of force per person
actually often to not share some of the
harder to hear stories
racism research systematizing access to
resources tutorial gbt and school
including addressing teachers
administrators room is really an ability
to interrupt bullying and harassment it
earns her we're transgender identified
and foster parents and permanency
resources so this is something within
the foster care system that's happening
at bullpen so the Saracens LGBTQ are
very harassed
in three parents issues appear and
harder interpersonal violence and their
relationship to systemic violence
participants own suggestions for systems
change that ll feedback about what they
thought was being done wrong to done
better
where are the exploration restored
restorative and transformative justice
models we're in transgender parenting
and children we're on transparent
so the next steps that are and
emotionality conduct a community forum
to grow too quietly back to community
members as providers to continue these
body research for advocacy translate
research findings continues